nous payons la facture de la lâcheté de
la naïveté par le centre nos
compatriotes et c'est inacceptable
c'était un professeur d'histoire hier
c'était un curé l'abbé hamel avant
c'était un chef d'entreprise de monsieur
corps nara qui a été rappelée vous
décapité en 2015
il ya eu charlie hebdo ce fut des
journalistes et voilà la triste réalité
de la france aujourd'hui avec un
président de la république qui nous
propose un projet de loi pour lutter
contre le séparatisme ou pour la
première fois il a osé nommer
l'ennemi c'est à dire lycée pas rater
gallus mais sans jamais prononcer le mot
apportant aussi qui est nécessaire
d'évoquer c'est l'immigration
je suis pour une régulation massive de
l'immigration et je ne souhaite pas que
ceux qui viennent demander l'asile
puissent circuler dans notre pays donc
en règle de chair c'est une limite le
nombre des masques massive ans et il
faut regarder en fonction aussi du des
pays d'origine moi je veux un quotas
migratoires voté chaque année au
parlement et par continent d'origine
j'attends de la part du gouvernement non
pas des paroles
j'attends des actes ferme quand
j'entends monsieur darmanin dire qui va
expulser 231 radicaliser s pour les
renvoyer les expulser 231,7 un effet
d'annonce il ya 3000 fichier s pour
radicalisation aujourd'hui étrangers
expulsés 3000 les ciels et il faut il
faut tout de suite je vais vous dire il
ne pourra pas parce que des procédures à
régler est donc plutôt que de dire qu'il
va faire 2 qui va renvoyer deux cent
trente et une personnes
voilà longtemps que le gouvernement
aurait dû s'atteler à cette tâche et
renvoyer immédiatement dès qu'ils le
peuvent
les fichiers s est rangé pour
radicalisation dehors
est-ce qu'on va encore tolérer longtemps
des gens qui veulent nous assassiner on
délivre des droits d'asile chez nous des
titres droit d'asile chez nous à des
gens qui sont opposés aux fondamentaux
de notre démocratie
ce n'est pas supportable le rôle du
gouvernement c'est de protéger les
français et donc oui c'est un acte de
guerre il faut riposter massivement pour
fermer les mosquées salafistes
est ce que vous savez que il ya aucun le
ministre l'intérieur serait incapable de
vous dire exactement combien il ya deux
mosquées dans d'autres pays
y at il un répertoire des mosquées de
savoir où elle se trouve
personne ne sait entre les lieux de
prière les mosquées et les imams peuvent
se déclarer et man mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire quand vous entendez sur cette
télévision al djazira expliqué que
monsieur macron est en train de faire
avec sa loi sur le séparatisme une
nouvelle croisade
mais où on est ici c'est la france on se
laissera pas imposer la loi des autres
et notamment pas celle qui vient d'une
religion qui a été importée à savoir
l'islam